chimène badi qui boit de la bâlois qui
chante j'ai essayé de partir je viens du
débat entre nous entre nouvelles
réponses
mais ça n'est pas dit si belle boxe je
n'ai pas été conçu à la troisième
attention dernier titre on y va à caen
soit c'est parti gilles si vous nous
rejoignez sur des beats et chimène
bâlois a tout de suite fait pas
attention on y va êtes prêts oui c'est
pas du camji giuly c'est pas du caddie
est en train de chercher la chanson car
elle croit pas ses oreilles
[Applaudissements]
si vous voulez garder alors ils
voulaient me garder et oui je n'aime à
mourir ou pas bien sûr attention c'est
la dernière c'est déjà l'homme a mûri
survient après ma mort et à face au
débat annoncé la dernière un noir c'est
noir géniale idée
[Applaudissements]